But she should get mugged.
That would be very Parisian.
At least feel people,
other people's hands
in her pockets.
That's very,
that happens a lot.
She needs to hold on
to her phone.
-Is that too mean? Okay.
-Oui.
Baguette. Croissant.
Je suis French.
Bonjour. Bonjour. Oh la la.
-Do you want your hat?
-No, I don't want...
This all looks a little bit
too much like congrés,
like a Marine Le Pen
meeting.
Too many French flags.
I almost said "bonjour".
Hi, I'm Marie.
I'm French. I live in Paris.
I'm Anaïs
and I live in Paris.
Which doesn't quite rhyme,
but still rhymes
more than "Emily in Paris".
I'm here to watch this show
and react to it.
Hope we'll change your mind
about French culture today.
We probably won' t
but it's fine.
Paris
is not a romantic city.
When you live there,
there's not much
that's romantic about it.
They are very wrong
about accordions.
The water in the Seine
is not blue.
It's not even like green.
It's this like mushy brown
and it's filled
with like radioactive waste.
Never dive in the Seine,
first of all.
-Bad water. Yeah.
-You'll die.
It's like "American"
is written on her forehead.
Hi.
-That is very realistic.
-I, I don't agree.
'Cause like we do say "hi".
We'd say 'hi"
more than Americans.
Americans don't say "hi"
when they get into stores
or stuff like this.
We have basic politeness.
I disagree. Profoundly.
Usually, you would have
like half of this staircase
falling down
and then you would have
little pieces of paper
everywhere in the building,
like writing
where it might collapse
at some point.
'Cause all buildings are...
What buildings do you go to?
Voilà. Your magnificent
chambre de bonne.
That is so not
a chambre de bonne.
Chambre de bonne
is like super tiny.
You basically
can have breakfast,
take a shower,
and sleep at the same time
in the same space.
And you don't have
three windows.
You're lucky if you have
one full window, so...
Oh my God!
I feel like Nicole Kidman
in Moulin Rouge!.
Sure.
This'd be madly expensive...
-Oui.
-...to live there, right?
Yeah. They used to cut
people's heads there
during the revolution.
It's true. True story.
So, you don't have
a boyfriend in Paris?
We've better looking people
than this.
Like, is he supposed to be
a hot French man?
It is.
Well, that's the problem
with Americans.
Each time they see
a Frenchman with an accent,
they think he's hot
and most of the time
they're not.
She wears
way too many colours.
Like, she's sticking out
like a sore thumb.
I like her clothes.
But her shoes.
Like she would already
be in the hospital
wearing those shoes
in Paris.
We have cobblestones
everywhere.
-Yeah.
-You can't wear this.
We open at 10:30.
-10:30.
-That never happens.
-Nowhere. Nowhere.
-Yeah.
Everyone's at the office
at like 08:50.
-Yeah. Max.
-Everywhere. Yeah.
Bonjour.
I love her. Very stylish.
And she's mean.
Do you wanna have lunch?
No.
No. I'll have a cigarette.
That is so cliche.
So, was she eating
a whole Camembert for lunch?
Yes.
That's why they don't
wanna eat with her.
-Can you imagine?
-Yeah.
-Do you love it?
-Oh yes, of course.
I love Paris,
but the people...
-It's always grey.
-So mean.
That's true.
We are mean.
Chinese people
are mean behind your back.
French people,
mean to your face.
-Yes.
That's the way to be mean.
If you have to be mean,
be mean to people's faces.
Don't be mean
behind their backs.
That's just mean.
Aw, that's not nice.
But I kinda get it.
Bonjour, la plouc.
That is very mean.
And that wouldn't happen.
We're not that mean.
No one would call,
like, "Hey, redneck".
No. We would say that
on the WhatsApp group...
Yeah. We would say like,
"She's such a plouc",
like on the private group.
I guess we are not mean
to people's faces.
Like we're mean
behind their backs, like...
No one's gonna call someone
who dresses like that
a plouc.
-That's not what a plouc is.
-No.
No, we'd say nouveau riche.
-You're a connasse.
-No, American...
You never flirt
with another woman
in front of your mistress.
It's worse
than in front of your wife.
I've seen many people
flirt with another woman
-in front of their mistress.
-Who has mistresses?
-Everyone.
-Who're these French people?
That's not true.
Stop spreading lies.
No, but what she's saying
is that you shouldn't flirt
with another woman
in front of your mistress.
You can do it
in front of your spouse,
but not your mistress.
That's weird.
That's just a dumb rule.
That's not a thing.
Yeah.
Just flirt, you know?
Yeah. Flirting,
that's like part of
the French constitution.
This steak
isn't cooked at all.
Pardon, monsieur?
It should be bloody.
-I mean rare.
-Order it blue.
That's the way we do it.
Just make sure to never
order the ris de veau.
Ris de veau so good, though.
Oh, it's perfect, yes.
Think it's brains or balls,
but it tastes like ass.
No,
it doesn't taste like ass.
Come on.
Customer is always right.
Customer
is never right in Paris.
Unless he is agreeing
with the owner and waiter.
Yes.
Customer service
is bad in France. True.
They don't work for tips
like they do in the US.
-'Cause we have labour laws.
-Exactly.
And you won't get salmonella
if you eat raw meat.
-No.
-'Cause our meat is good.
If you do get salmonella,
do not sue us.
It's always nice.
Never rains in this Paris.
Paris is so pretty.
Makes me wanna live there.
And I already do.
She's the woman who thinks
Macron is hot in that show.
I can't sleep...
Oh my God.
-That is accurate, though.
-Yes.
Like I've seen many men
pee on the streets
over the past year.
No, sorry. That's my bad.
I, you're peeing
and that's a urinal.
-Au revoir, monsieur.
-Bonne journée.
If you really
wanna be accurate,
you have to show
them jerking off too.
'Cause that happens a lot
in Paris.
In the middle
of the streets.
Now that's France for you.
Without the running.
Yeah, exactly.
-That's very accurate.
-Yeah.
French cars will kill you.
But French men
will do that to you.
That's not true.
I'm on a train.
This is not a French train.
I don't know where
they found this train, but--
This is a theme park.
No one's ever taken a train
like this in France.
-I mean, maybe...
-Not since the 50s.
-And even then.
-Yeah.
All I want for her
is to go on the metro
to take a TGV, a Ouigo,
a cheap TGV, a cheap train.
- Un Intercité.
I want her to know
the real struggle
-of moving around France.
-Yeah.
Although, we do have
a great train system,
but like, it's not luxurious
like this.
No. Behind him,
that's a real train.
-Yeah.
-That's a real train,
but what are they in?
This is not...
It looks like
the Orient Express,
-but that's so dramatic.
-Yeah.
-Wait, where are you going?
-That's French, though.
I'm not going
to Saint-Tropez
with a girl
in love with someone else.
You're not going
to Saint-Tropez at all
because there are no trains
that go to Saint-Tropez,
so...
-Not this one.
-Check the itinerary.
I love her look.
Camille's look.
Yeah. I want that jacket.
He's just busy
with the new restaurant.
Does anyone have a euro
for la dame pipi?
Dame pipi? No.
We haven't see dame pipi
since the eighties.
Like, I think I saw
three in my life.
Like dame pipi...
Well, there are some
in the train stations,
but not at a restaurant
that is that fancy.
Also, we don't call them
dame pipi.
That's very rude.
-Yeah. Literally means...
-Call her "the nice lady".
...lady peepee.
That's it for now.
Thanks for watching.
And we hope we rectified
some misconceptions
you guys might have
about Paris.
-Come to Paris.
-Don't!
Please don't.
Too many tourists right now.
It's traumatic.